- Yo, what up everybody?
Hope you're enjoying your
holiday as much as I am,
family time, but wanted to
set up this next keynote.
Did this at the Nordic forum.
Lot of new topics.
Went pretty deep with a bunch of people.
Hope you enjoy it.
See you soon.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
(Gary laughing)
Thank you, Finland.
I'm super excited to be here.
And really very honestly, I'd
like to get the Q&A portion
of this pretty quickly.
I wrote a book called #ASKGARYVEE
because I do believe
that these kind of events
are incredible and that
a lot of very smart
and special people come and
pontificate and what have you,
but the interaction is
the single greatest way
to get deep, instead of wide.
And I think at the end
of the day for everybody
that has decided to
come to this conference,
there's tangible things we want.
There's something we want.
And that's actually where I want to start.
Actually, you know what,
let's start with this.
Before I go into this, by show of hands,
how many people here have no idea who I am
or anything about my spiel?
Tell the truth, raise them.
That fucking hurts.
(audience laughs)
Thank you, Finland,
I'll see you next time.
That's a tough way to start.
I thought that was the
case and I understand why.
So I'm gonna spend a few minutes
giving you my background,
because I think it's the foundation
of what I want to bring here.
I did a lot of work on
the flight over here
to understand the audience.
I think a lot of times,
when I speak at conferences
or other speakers speak,
we make some misdistinctions of B2B, B2C,
things of that nature.
And so understanding the
makeup of a lot of people
in this audience and
understanding the landscape
of the social media
grid, the digital grid,
I'm gonna try to factor
my talk very aggressively
towards a little bit more
of a B2B environment.
It's interesting, as a
marketer and a business person,
so many people think when
they think about social media,
it's so much more in a B2C environment.
Yet GE, which is one
of our largest clients
of my firm Vayner Media, is
easily the happiest client
we have because at the end of the day,
before I give you my background,
I want to set this up immediately,
which is the following.
No matter what you do in this room,
no matter what business you come from,
no matter what position you
hold within that organization,
whether you're a solo entrepreneur
or work at a big organization,
there's only one thing
that bounds us all together
in this room.
The number one thing from
a business perspective
that ties all of us together
in this room is quite simple.
At the end of the day,
before you tell me how great
your SaaS product is, or your service,
or how delicious your wine is,
or how great you are if
you're building your brand,
no matter what, before you
get a chance to tell me
how great you are or it is or that is,
you need somebody's attention.
The number one thing that
everybody here is battling on,
the currency of business forever,
and everything, by the way, is attention.
And the biggest thing that
everybody in this room
is being affected, and this is worldwide,
whether I'm in Asia,
South America, the US.
Obviously the apps are slightly different.
The usage is different.
But the one thing that is common,
the one thing that I
absolutely want to spend
the majority of my time on is
you're sitting in this room
and you do not understand the
slide that I have up there
that says I day trade
attention and build businesses,
you are very vulnerable in the speed
of which the market is changing.
If you do not understand
that if you are religious
or emotional of where
you send your message,
whether that is print
or radio or television
or conferences or direct
mail or Facebook, Twitter,
Snapchat or Tumblr, if you are emotional,
if you draw lines in the sand,
if you talk about how you used to do it
or how your grandfather built the business
or what is tried and true,
in a 2017 world, you are
massively vulnerable.
The speed in which our consumers,
whether in a B2B or B2C environment,
are switching and moving
has never been faster.
And listen, I stand in front of you,
I know Dick Costolo's here,
the former CEO of Twitter,
I saw him backstage, a
very good friend of mine.
My breakout in the States was Twitter.
I was one of the first
movers on that platform.
I amassed a million followers on Twitter.
I would wish and want
that Twitter was still
the number one place that
everyone spent all their time on.
I was on the top of the heap.
But as it started getting
competition from Instagram
and Snapchat and other platforms,
and as the attention was not
as deeply in that platform,
it hurt my feelings.
I wasn't excited that I spent
all of 2007 through 2010,
eight fucking hours a
day replying to people
of what wine goes with fish.
(audience laughs)
Every day, eight hours
a day, to build a base.
I wasn't excited that people
were moving away from it.
I just knew that I had no choice,
that that was the punchline.
That as much as you'd
like it to be the way
that it most benefits you,
the end consumer does other stuff.
And so that's basically
been the story of my life.
My life starts in being born in Belarus
in the former Soviet Union.
I came tot he US when
I was three years old.
We were very, very, very poor.
I lived in a studio apartment
with eight family members,
a third of the size of
the stage I'm on now.
And my dad and my mom, as you can imagine,
are very much my heroes.
My dad worked every hour of his life,
being a stock boy in a liquor store.
Actually, how many people
in this room are immigrants
or children of immigrants?
Please raise your hand.
Just curious.
So for the hands that are in this room,
they know something I know, which is
immigrants have an amazing advantage.
They have a very tried and true strategy
that we could all learn from.
What immigrants are very good at doing is
when they come to a new country,
they work and they don't spend any money
on dumb shit for 10 years.
And so that's what my parents did.
And eventually my dad was able
to buy a small liquor store
in New Jersey.
I was a very entrepreneurial kid.
I was day trading
attention from a young age.
I had six lemonade stands
when I was seven years old
and I would spend all my
time trying to figure out
what tree and what pole
to put the signs on,
because I was watching people drive
and trying to figure out what signs.
I was a very sick child.
When I was 12 and 13, I
was selling baseball cards,
which were very popular in
the United States at the time.
And I was making one to $2,000 a weekend
selling them in the malls of New Jersey,
which was great and I
was rich for a young kid,
and it was fantastic.
But then my career changed.
My dad dragged me into the liquor store.
And I hated it at first,
but luckily I realized
that people collected wine.
I was into collecting sports memorabilia.
That was my passion,
that was the connection.
And I decided that I was going to jump
into my family business,
open up 4,000 liquor
stores across America,
sell the franchise one day,
and buy the New York Jets
American football team,
because that is my dream.
You two stand up, you two stand up.
Let's clap it up for these guys.
(audience applauding)
In 1994, I was in my dorm room in college.
My friend came over to me,
and I wanna start wrapping this up
and getting into what matters to you.
He brought me into a room.
It was the first time I heard
(mimicking an old modem),
which was the internet.
I was very excited about it.
I didn't know what it was.
I said something stupid like,
"Is this the information superhighway?"
I looked at it.
This is, you know, there's
a lot of youngsters in here.
This is 1994.
I literally stood there and
watched people on the internet
for five hours.
It was that crazy.
It was just that insane, it was so new.
And when I finally had
my turn to go on there,
when I finally had my turn to go on there,
within 20 minutes, I
landed on a message board
where people were trading and
buying cards, baseball cards.
And I realized, my God, I can
do business on this thing.
And over the next year, I went head first
and learned about eBay,
learned about what was going on in Amazon,
started learning the
early internet culture.
And in 1996, I launched winelibrary.com,
one of the first two e-commerce
wine businesses in America.
From 1998 to 2003, in a five-year window,
I grew my dad's business from a three
to a $60 million business on
very, very important terms
that matter to this entire room.
I had no money.
It was a $3 million business
that had 10% gross profit,
$300,000 before expenses.
There was no marketing budget.
What I needed is to make every
penny work like a dollar.
So the strategy became
day trading attention.
When you day trade attention, my friends,
here's what you do.
You don't overspend on
what everybody believes
is tried and true.
Every single company in this
gorgeous conference right now
is grossly overspending money on things
that they've been doing
for the last decade,
'cause it's the things they accept,
or the reporting justifies it,
or they're just lazy to try something new.
Everyone, everyone.
And so what you do when
you day trade attention
is you have to find angles.
What's underpriced?
How many people here do email marketing
or have done email
marketing in their lives?
Raise your hands.
Perfect, a lot of you.
In 1997, I started an email newsletter.
Most people that came into my liquor store
didn't even know what email was in 1997.
I collected, I collected, I collected.
And in 1998, I had a
200,000-person email newsletter
with 91% open rates.
Now it's not because I was a genius.
And I know a lot of you
sit here, just like I do,
with emails that are 13
to 23% open rates today.
It's that in 1997, nobody was emailing.
We hadn't ruined it yet.
One thing I promise you,
more than I know that the
sun will come up tomorrow,
I know that marketers ruin everything.
We ruined the internet,
I'm trying to ruin Snapchat
and Music.ly right now.
We ruin shit, it's what we do.
So it was 91% open rates there.
Then Google AdWords came out.
I bought the word wine on Google AdWords
for five cents a click and
owned it for nine months
before anybody bid me up.
Because people were still on Yahoo,
and AskJeeves, and other shit like that.
So that became the rinse and repeat.
As I think about B2B
players in this environment,
it is stunning to me how
many B2B businesses here
do not understand that producing articles
on Medium.com, on LinkedIn,
writing full content on
Facebook on your feed
and then spending $100 in ads
against employees of the company
that you're trying to reach.
Let me say that three more times,
because the one thing I promised myself
as I boarded last night
in New York to get here is
I'm gonna give my talk.
But I'm gonna give every
single person in this audience
one thing to take home to do,
and then email and say thank you.
So let me say it really slow.
Right now, on this day, October 6, right?
Is that right?
October 6, 2016, the number one deal,
if you day trade attention like I do,
in this market is Facebook ads.
They are underpriced.
They are underpriced, because
a lot of people in this room
still debate what the ROI is.
Or even worse, they're emotional
that Facebook organic reach
has come down and now
they have to pay for it.
While you're emotional and sad
that you don't reach as many things,
the best ad product that I've
seen since Google AdWords
has emerged.
Or even worse than both
of those two scenarios,
you haven't even done it yet.
You've decided for your business,
your customer's not on that platform,
yet you've never spent a dollar testing it
to know if that's true or not.
You've read a headline,
you had a friend tell you,
but you don't actually do
it, and you're not sure.
We live in a world right
now of headline readers.
Everybody here has a lot
of opinions about Facebook
and Snapchat and Instagram and Influencer,
LinkedIn and Medium.
But there's very few practitioners.
There's very few people that
have actually placed the ads.
There are very few people that understand
that the creative is the
variable when you place an ad.
And just because you
did it once doesn't mean
that it doesn't work.
It might mean that the creative,
the video and the picture
that you put out, just sucked.
And so, as I go through
all the other things,
just in the middle here for a few minutes,
I just wanna tell you exactly what I know.
What I know is I'm involved with 15
different B2B businesses right now.
GE is a client.
AT&T is a client.
But many start-ups that I
invest in because I also
in my mid-2000s started
investing in Twitter,
Facebook, Tumblr, Uber.
I've done very well in that world.
I basically just told you that to brag.
That had no information value.
But what I know about
these B2B businesses is
right now every single person here
can write an article about their expertise
in the business that they're in.
Not a propaganda for your
SaaS product or service,
but an article that would be valuable
to the people that you're trying to reach.
You can write this article
literally in a Facebook post,
literally in a Facebook post.
And then you can go to the ad product
and you can actually target employees of,
one of the ways you can target on Facebook
is the employees of an organization.
How many people here are
in B2B, raise your hand.
Higher, go high for me
Helsinki, higher again.
Show me again, I need to look, high.
Perfect.
A shitload, a lot of you.
All of you, all of you need to hear this.
This is the remarkable era
of underpriced opportunity
in digital and social marketing,
yet I'm empathetic to why most
of you do not believe that.
I get it.
Most of the advice,
most of the conferences,
most of the articles position
this in a B2C environment.
I know, for example, the following,
that if I was to buy
one of your companies,
the number one thing I
would do is the following.
Every one of you are in an industry
where there is a B2B magazine
that is the number one thing
that the people in your market read.
If you are a company
trying to reach customers,
I would become that magazine.
Let me explain.
The other religious point
of view that this room needs
to take away from this talk this weekend,
or at some point you will
believe this is true,
whether it is today or
12 or 24 months from now,
36 months from now, is the following.
The quicker everybody
in this room understands
that they are a media company,
comma, software company,
comma, wine retailer, comma, lawyer,
comma, account service provider,
the quicker everybody
in this room understands
that they are a media
company, comma, those things,
the quicker you will be successful.
I will tell you why.
You told me that earlier
they said the ad was dead.
You said the ad has gotta
be creative and good,
give it to the creatives.
I believe more in your world
and I'll just add to it.
The ad has to bring value.
The number one thing
that's happening in society
in every part of the
world is the following.
We as human beings, no
matter where we're from,
we value health, we wanna
stay alive and the people,
money, you like money.
But the number one
emerging thing in society
in value is time.
Time is exploding in value to us
because we all now live
in a 24/7, 365 world.
Some of the old-timers in this room,
remember when the work day
ended and it just ended?
It wasn't getting emails at night,
people expecting you to reply.
We now live in a 24/7 world.
As a matter of fact, one
of the great mistakes
of my investing career is Travis
Kalanick, the CEO of Uber,
who's a very good friend of mine,
I passed on investing in Uber
in the angel round twice.
I cost myself hundreds
of millions of dollars.
I'm very upset about it.
But I invested a little bit later on,
not because Uber was doing so well,
but because I realized
when he came to New York,
and my brother AJ took
the first Uber ride,
oh my God, Uber doesn't
sell transportation.
Uber sells time.
We don't care about
privacy, we care about time.
This is who we are as humans.
And what advertising is
doing in the last 50 years
is it's stopping you from
doing what you want to do
and it's selling you something,
which means by nature it
is stealing your time.
Which is why the second you decide
that you're a media company
and you actually want to bring
people value, instead of
selling them something, you win.
If you run home now and
misunderstood what I said,
which is why I'm creating
clarity right now for you,
if you leave here and
misunderstood what I said,
you will go home, you
will make a Facebook post,
and you will write a
propaganda or sales post
and you will push it and
it will not be successful.
If you heard me loud
and clear and understand
who you're trying to reach
and you write an article
about something that brings
them value, you will win.
For example, a small
business in the United States
that heard this talk
three years ago from me
started writing content about golf.
They were a law firm.
But what they understood was
the people they were trying
to reach were into golf.
And they started writing
content about golf
and used that content as a gateway drug
to close the clients.
Because people don't want
to read your sales pitch.
They don't have time.
People want to read
something that brings value.
And the interesting thing
about so many of you
in the B2B environment is
you're actually an expert
or knowledgeable about your craft.
You actually know.
And so putting that content to
work is massively important.
It was super important for
me six, seven years ago.
That was nothing compared
to the ability of going
and now targeting the
employees of the organization
that you're trying to reach.
For example, if you're
trying to reach the CTO
or the CIO, or if you
actually know the title
of the person you're trying to reach,
you are able to make a video on Facebook
that shows the value prop of your product.
You're able to then in the copy say,
"Does your CIO know?"
You're then able to run $100 worth of ads
against the employees
of that organization.
And then 20 people from that organization
are going to take that post and forward it
to the CIO, the CTO, the head of finance,
or whoever you're trying to reach.
My friends, I've spent the
last seven minutes here
on this rant.
And I understand it's very tactical
and it's not motivational and funny.
But I fucking promise you
that if you really understand
what I'm talking about,
you will do what you actually care to do,
which is sell shit.
Right?
We're running businesses here.
So please, please understand that.
Because once you understand
what I just spent my time on,
how that works, you'll
start understanding why
every company here needs
to hire an editor-in-chief.
An editor-in-chief for your
SaaS business, your law firm.
An editor-in-chief, it's crazy.
It's not something any of you would think,
and I understand why.
But you have to understand
the playing field is changing.
And it's changing fast.
In America, I run Vayner Media.
We're an 800-person firm,
$100 million in revenue,
in four years from zero, basically.
We work with GE and Pepsi and Under Armor
and Toyota and the biggest
brands in the world.
And in the US, my clients spend
tens of billions of dollars
trying to sell stuff.
Here's how they do it.
By show of hands in this room,
how many of you now watch television,
not when the show airs, but on TiVo,
Netflix, DVR, or Amazon Prime,
whatever you have here on your time.
Raise your hands.
Oh interesting, everybody.
Everybody.
And I think we can agree
this is not 13-year-old girls
everywhere, right, everybody.
And how many of you,
when given the chance,
fast-forward every single commercial
if you have the option of fast-forward?
Miraculous, everybody.
Yet every company that is trying to reach
and sell you something
here in the Finland market
is spending millions of dollars
making 30-second videos to
put in between these shows
to sell you something.
And even if miraculously that
video is put in front of you
because you dropped your
remote control off the bed,
even if that miraculous thing happens,
the second a commercial comes,
every person in this room grabs this.
And you look at this
and you check on work,
or you tweet about what you just saw
or you wanna see what other people said
about what she was wearing.
But I promise you one thing.
Your attention,
your attention is not on that video.
You can sit with me for the
next 30 years of your life
and show me every report you have,
your modeling mix, your data reports,
your big data, your surveys.
You can show me all your
report, but my friends,
it is time for the people in this room,
and especially the
entrepreneurs in this room
to start deploying common
sense against this reality.
In America, the number
one thing that my clients
spend money on is
programmatic banner ad buy-in.
Banner ads across the whole web.
There's nobody in this room
that is looking at a banner ad.
Nobody is going to a website,
scrolling down to the
bottom left-hand corner,
and carefully consuming a banner.
It's true.
(audience applauding)
And you clap, and you clap,
my friends, because you know.
Yet many sell it, many buy it,
because that's what humans do.
You do what's best for
you in the short term
without understanding the
long-term implications.
We are living through a revolution.
This, my friends, this is the television.
And the television is the radio.
And it's 1960 and there's
a huge opportunity
for everybody in this room.
And you can sit and give excuses when I
and Dick and Peter come up and say,
"Ah, but here in Finland it's different."
(audience laughing and applauding)
You can say that.
You're more than welcome.
But the reason you laughed and clapped
is 'cause you know it's not.
I know it's not 'cause I look at the data.
I'm not emotional about it.
I don't care how reserved you are.
I don't care how over the top I am.
This is just data.
Your consumers are living on this device.
And when you sit and make another excuse,
"Yes, Gary, you're very interesting.
"You're a very interesting
speaker, this is good.
"But my customer is not
on that, they're older."
You're older.
(audience laughing)
You're on it.
(audience applauding)
And so, I had a very big
advantage going into marketing.
Unlike many people,
and it's why I love the
speaker tomorrow, Seth Godin,
who I enjoy so much,
and I'm sure you will.
He actually built a business
before he became a marketing expert.
I built businesses and sell stuff
before I started a marketing firm.
My big advantage is my KPI, my ROI
is not headlines and adage.
It's not to win a award
in the south of France.
My KPI and ROI is to sell something.
That's what businesses do.
And so I implore all of
you to take a hard look,
because here's the punchline.
And I'm sure, I didn't get
to see what Peter said,
but I sure know how he rolls.
If you think about what
has happened in our society
over the last 10 years,
and this is worldwide,
if you understand what's gonna happen
over the next 10 years, it is remarkable.
As a matter of fact, this is
actually a very good question.
How many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years?
And I don't mean, before
you raise your hand,
I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and make lots of money
and retire on a island.
I mean, you're old and you're finished.
(audience laughing)
Raise your hand if you're
retiring in the next 10 years.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay, so for the nine of you,
(audience laughing)
you could take some of what
I said with a grain of salt.
But for the rest of
you, please understand.
If you are not a practitioner,
whether you are the
CEO, the head of sales,
or entry level in your career,
if you don't understand
how this stuff works,
if you've not signed up
for Instagram and Snapchat,
this is not a waste of your time.
Think of it this way.
We are running a marathon.
And if you don't start
getting on the treadmill
and getting ready for the marathon,
when the marathon comes,
you will not be able to run.
You understand?
So downloading these things
and understanding these things
is not for fun or being cool.
It's gonna be the only game.
What do you think is happening here?
There are 60-year-old men in here
who sent the poop emoji
in the last 24 hours.
We're changing the way we communicate.
There are people in this
room that 10 years ago said
they would never get a cell phone
'cause their pager was good enough.
We are living through major, major,
major communication shifts.
And it is gonna be expedential.
We live in a mobile-only world.
You just don't realize it yet.
It's here, it's happening.
And whether Twitter becomes
big and then not big,
whether Facebook's here in five
years or not, I don't care.
I don't care, Facebook,
Snapchat, Twitter, Instagram,
Tumblr, Pinterest all disappear.
The concept of us consuming information
and making business decisions
and living our lives through this is here.
And then it will be here.
And then we'll be fucking robots.
But now, but for now,
but for now it is here.
And if your entire business
strategy is not about
where people's attention is,
when you look at the data of
finish use on the internet
today and on cell phone usage,
when you look at your
customers in this country,
not in America, of the percentage of time
that everybody in Finland
spends on a social network
in a mobile device, it is up
to almost 50% of all usage.
Only gaming and utility
apps are anywhere close.
All of a sudden, the word social media,
instead of some little thing on the side,
a little sprinkle, a little nice-to-have,
when you think the way I think,
which this is the most
important device in the world,
and more than half of our time, all of us,
half of our time in this device is spent
on a social network, it becomes
a little more important.
I mean literally, guys, when
I go out tonight in Helsinki,
I would rather have
somebody come up to me,
stab me in the stomach with
a knife and steal my wallet
than lose my phone.
This is it.
How many people here in
every 24-hour window,
every 24-hour window, are in
arms' reach of their telephone?
Raise your hand.
What do you think is happening?
You think your, like
who can't wait to leave
this amazing conference, the
Nordic Business Conference,
go home, and go to their mailbox,
and carefully go through
their direct mail?
I mean, what are we spending our money on?
How do you think you're getting customers?
It is time.
Listen, you could get away
with this bullshit in 2009
and say it's not here.
You could, you could,
when I was here at a
different conference in 2012,
you could say, eh, not yet.
My friends, it's 2017.
The data's in place.
You may not like it.
You may go out to dinner with your partner
and you may see two
people sitting at dinner
and both of them are on a phone.
And you may say, ah, look how sad that is.
Technology, so sad.
You can do that.
You many not like that this is happening.
By the way, real quick, when
I see a couple at dinner
and they're on the phone the whole time,
I don't think that's sad.
I think it's amazing.
Let me explain why.
That same couple, 15 years ago,
they just sat across
from each other at dinner
and didn't say a fucking word.
(audience laughing and applauding)
Let me say one thing here for you.
And this is a very good
thing for everybody
to leave this conference with.
Technology is not changing us.
Technology is exposing
who we actually are.
So all my friends, I have a
seven, four-year-old daughter.
All my friends are like,
ugh, I hate that my kids
are on the iPad all day.
But the second the kid
cries when we're over
and having drinks, they
throw the iPad at them
like it's medicine.
So it's time for us all
to not be hypocrites.
It is time for all of us
to understand it's 2017.
You may not like this.
You know what I love?
I love how everybody has
decided writing a letter
is so amazing.
We decided in the world
that if you write a letter,
that's some amazing achievement,
that you're the greatest
person of all time.
We have made the pencil
and paper on a pedestal.
Yet if we text each other,
that seems like not communicating.
Our kids are not communicating.
It's the same shit.
It's the same shit, do you understand?
And the longer you hold out,
and you want it to be 2002 and 1997
and 1983, great, knock yourself out.
But let me make you a promise.
Technology will run you over.
Somebody who's smaller than
you will take your business,
because the attention, the
attention of all of our consumers
and all of age groups and
all demos and all countries
in 2017 is here.
And when you understand what
people pay attention to here,
it is Facebook, it is YouTube,
it is blogs, it is
LinkedIn, it is Twitter.
And you better figure
out how you storytell
and how you market on these platforms,
because if you don't,
you will be finished.
Thank you.
(audience applauding and cheering)
(upbeat music)
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- [Man] Gary!
What an amazing performance, my God.
What a wake up call that
was, thank you so much.
Give him a hand one more time.
- And hold on, and hold on.
- Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Is anybody else pissed off
like I am that it is 2016
and that needs to be a wake-up call?
- Unfortunately, that is the case.
That is the case.
And it feels damn good to be awakened.
- Good.
- Common sense.
You know, but I do enjoy
going to southern France
to pick up a prize once in a while.
But you know that's--
- It feels good.
- We've got a huge amount of questions.
I think the one that I want to use--
(man yelling in the audience)
- I'll give you this perhaps if, yes,
you changed your clothes.
- [Antti] That's what I did.
- You are so, what are you wearing?
Tell me that first, please.
- He's wearing my favorite
football player's jersey.
Al Toon was a Jet from 1984 to '88.
- There you go.
- 1985 to '92.
- Yes.
- Look at this guy.
- Wide receiver, 6,605 yards.
- [Gary] What college did he go to?
- Don't know.
- Wisconsin, all right,
let's do the questions,
'cause I want to answer the question.
Go ahead.
- Gary, uh,
thanks for being here.
My name is Antti Merilehto.
Finch Filand is one of my companies.
I do have a question
because I'm half immigrant.
My wife, she's a coach in Boston
so I spend half the time in Boston,
half the time here.
And I would say for me,
being in front of you,
all of you, wearing this strange clothing
for a business conference
is more natural than for
many people around here.
And, by the way, you're
on live on my Facebook.
- [Gary] No problem.
- [Man] And your question was?
- My question is, how can
you encourage these people,
Fins who are a bit
different, we're more shy,
to be here and day trade their attention
and like for me saying,
if you have eCommerce, in other
words, I'm the guy to go to
if you spend more than 5K a month.
How can people be, stand up, do it?
- [Gary] Yeah, I get it. I get it.
Look, I think, and I addressed it earlier,
listen, every culture
has it's own game, right.
Like I don't think, I have no interest,
and I definitely don't have
the audacity or the hypocrisy
to come here and say be like me,
be crazy, wear a jersey from
a different football team
from a different country.
Stand up, disrupt the entire conference.
- He's a typical Finish guy.
- What I love about that is,
that's real for you Antti,
that's real for you.
And you should do that.
And for a lot of people here,
if you're introverted, for example,
the example I spent most of
my time on the talk today,
it wasn't about being
crazy on video like I am.
That's what I'm comfortable with.
Some people are just great writers.
Maybe you use SoundCloud and you do audio.
Everybody here has to deploy
one very important thing,
self-awareness.
You have to know who you are.
You shouldn't be crazy because there's
not a lot of crazy in Finland.
You shouldn't be reserved or introverted
because that's what's expected.
You need to be you.
And you need to be you,
and you need to be you.
And once you get
comfortable with being you,
it's unbelievable what starts happening.
Now, whether it is through
written form, audio, video,
you need to figure out the medium
that allows you to
communicate to the world
and in which platforms here
because you will very successful
if you can figure that out.
By not talking, by not communicating
in the best form for you,
where people actually are,
you are leaving money, opportunity,
raising money for charities,
whatever you want to
accomplish in your life,
you're leaving that on a table.
So the punchline is self-awareness man.
I'm not gonna tell them, go do this.
I don't know them.
I don't know you.
Do you. You know you.
Stop being scared of who you are.
- [Man] Be yourself.
(audience applause)
Be yourself. Everybody else is taken.
We know that one, I think it's so clear.
We have one question, I'm
gonna take a digital question,
I'll get back to you in a second.
You know because you did tell
us that you were there before
everybody was on Yahoo,
you were on Google before everybody else.
And this is a good question for you is,
what's next on social media?
Where are were going, you know?
Where are we going wrong
and where should we be?
- I have no idea.
- [Man] Thank you.
(audience laughs)
Next question please.
- Now, I'll expand.
- I'm just kidding.
- But I think it's the truth.
I think the biggest mistake people think,
and Seth gets it, I'm sure,
and Peter gets it and all these great-
we're not futurists, I'm
not Nostradamus, right.
I don't know what's happening next.
Here's what I know,
I put in the work when
I see something pop.
For the last eighth weeks on
the iTunes iStore, AppStore,
there's an app called Marco Polo
that has been in the top 150
so I downloaded it.
And I made my team download it.
And I watch people using it and I use it.
I taste it.
And I'm not crippled.
You know, so many people here think,
well that's a waste of time
if it doesn't become big.
I think it's a big disadvantage
for you not to do it
in case it becomes big.
So I play with Socialcam and Plurk
and all these things
that nobody talks about.
But I equally played with
Twitter and Facebook and Tumblr
and Snapchat and Instagram.
The key is, I don't know what's next
but every time I see something
that is happening a little bit,
I put in the work.
On Vine, when Vine was
popping two years ago,
I stayed up from midnight to
two o'clock in the morning
'cause I was very busy.
And I used it every night
and I watched everybody.
I watch people behave.
I have one thing, I have one talent.
I know what you're gonna do
before you know you're gonna do it.
- [Man] That's a good talent.
- And I do it by intuition
but also looking at the data.
And also watching.
And then watching what you do with it.
So to me, I don't know what's next.
I just know that the second
something pops a little bit,
unlike most of you,
I'm not scared to put in
the work to figure it out.
- [Man] Yes. Great answer.
(audience applause)
We have another eager gentleman.
Tell us who you are please.
- Hey Gary, my name is Antti.
Since the USC talk in 2015,
you've been like my digital uncle.
Like you kinda answer all my questions.
- [Gary] Yo, why can't we be brothers?
What are you saying I'm old?
- [Antti] You can be
my digital big brother.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Antti] Alright.
I was thinking, like, do I have
a question for Gary anymore
'cause you've answered so many questions
but I've figured out.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Our company is gonna explode
if we manage to scale our story.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Antti] And I'm gonna need
a lot of people for that.
And let's put it this way,
I'm gonna get the money to scale
from you or Seth or someone else.
I think you should do it
because we're about time
and about attention.
- [Gary] Okay.
- But, so my question is,
I come to the states
and I want Vayner Media
to do our marketing there.
- [Gary] Okay.
But you have 800 people so
when I buy from Vayner Media
I wanna buy what you know.
So how have you managed
to scale the culture
so that the person who's
handling my accounts
is gonna be as good as you?
- [Gary] They're not.
(audience laughs)
- [Antti] So its cheaper than
getting it straight from you?
- [Gary] Yes. I'm very expensive.
No, so here's the punchline.
My challenge wasn't to hire people-
listen, first of all,
anybody that's as good as me
would not work for me, let's
be very smart about this.
My job is not to make
you be able to buy me.
My job is to make sure that
everybody in my company,
when we have an account, is better
than anything else you could buy.
That's the game.
The game is not, me.
Nobody buys me.
I'm very up front with clients,
clients want to buy me and I explain,
I'm a CO of the company,
I run the company.
I'm setting the vision.
I need to be working on Marco
Polo and understanding that.
When I decided video for the phone
was the most important
thing a few years ago,
I was the one who hired
the first 20 people
that would make video for the phone.
Those are the things I have to do.
My game is not to do that.
My game is to create a culture internally
of being better than the
alternative in the market place.
- [Antti] Okay, so for a culture,
how do you chose the right people, one?
And how do you make
sure they're good enough
when they, for example, become a manager-
- [Gary] So I think the biggest
mistake people make here
that are running businesses,
is they are spending
too much time on hiring
and not enough strategy on firing.
So, I mean this,
and I know it's a funny thing to say.
I think I have unbelievable
emotional intelligence.
It's my intuition.
I have great people skills.
It's the thing I probably pride-
you know this, it's the thing
I pride myself the most on.
I am stunned how many times
I've been wrong hiring.
It's hard, it's hard.
So what I do now is I actually
don't spend any time on hiring.
When I built Vayner Media, this time,
from 30 to 200 people we
made happen in a year,
I hired everybody.
I mean, you could walk in and like say,
I don't have a computer,
I'm like, hired, you know.
I hired everybody because
when you're scaling,
I need to taste it.
It's much like the apps,
I don't know what's next but I'll try it
and then I'll know.
You don't know what you
have in an employee.
When you have to do is be upfront.
Hey John, you have to understand,
I'm hiring quickly, I don't
know if you're gonna be good,
but in three or four months,
if I don't think you're good,
we're probably gonna let you go.
And I wanna be up front with you
because you may not want on your resume
that you only worked here for three months
so you're taking a risk here too.
You have to be upfront.
You have to a standup.
But that's my strategy.
How do I know?
We hired, now we're at scale,
we know better what to look for
but we're not always right.
But the key is to make
sure people can't stay
in the system if they're not
qualified first, emotionally.
If you are not good with
the other boys and girls,
you are fired. Even if you're the best.
Second, meritocracy.
You have to be good enough
to carry your weight
because we're not running
a nonprofit either, got it?
So, that's how.
- Thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- [Annti] And this is the last
question, the biggest one.
Can I take you to dinner tonight?
- [Gary] I can't do that
but it was great to see you.
- [Annti] Thank you so much.
- [Man] Listen, we know
we're talking about
advantages at this conference
and you know, Finland has
many advantages that you
probably have already seen
but we have some disadvantages
when it comes to wine.
You know, the weather is
not very good for wine.
But we do have great spirit.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Or great spirits.
And would you accept to taste
one of Finland's most
famous spirit for us?
- [Gary] Now?
- Yes, right now.
- [Gary] Alright.
- Alright.
Alka, would you come here please?
(audience claps)
This is a bit of a
taste test for you Gary,
come on over here.
And this is a very special.
Alka is gonna pour you
something called Marskin ryyppy.
(audience laughs)
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Alka] I'm good and you?
- [Man] And there are two
questions related to this.
It has to be filled to the
brim, is the tradition.
- [Alka] Yes.
- [Gary] Shit.
This is- I talked to you about this.
It's Marshal Mannerheim, a great war hero,
a president of the republic,
had one of his staff invent this drink.
- Fuck.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] I want you to
tell us what you think.
But also it has three spirits in it.
What are they?
- I'm only pounding this
'cause I love all of you.
Alright, here we go.
L'chaim.
- [Man] L'chaim.
Oh my god, give him a big hand.
(audience applause)
You have become an honorary Finn.
What did you think of that?
Your commentary please.
- I think I have more hair on my chest.
(audience laughs)
Um, not bad, not bad actually.
Licorice. A little bit of almost,
do you know what pine tar is?
So a little pine tar.
Eucalyptis.
- [Man] Okay.
- [Gary] And what's in it?
- [Man] Yes, what do you think?
- You know-
- [Man] Very famous, you
know actually main stream-
- It's- to me it's got vodka, Sambuca...
Yeah, I mean, vodka stands out for me.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Um...
- [Man] Good one, good one.
- Maybe a little hint of gin.
- [Man] Yes. Very good.
A hint of gin, a bit of vodka
or what we call vena in this country,
but vermouth.
- Vermouth, got it.
- [Man] Give him a big
hand for trying that,
give him a big hand.
(audience applause)
(Gary laughs)
How about taking, you know,
a question from these guys?
On this side, anybody want
to ask a question to Gary V?
Ask Gary V, #GaryV.
- [Gary] Do you want me to answer this
while somebody's coming up?
- [Man] Oh, we have somebody over there.
We have somebody who's-
could you come up here and
catch this box for us please-
- I'm gonna answer this
while they're waiting.
It says, how do you prioritize your time-
- That's my next one for you.
- Okay you want-
- Your gonna-
- Geez, you're very rigid.
- I'm rigid man.
- For somebody with orange
pants, he's very rigid.
- I asked him to come up for you.
He has one there, he's good.
And then we'll take that, if that's okay.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Good?
- [Man] You're on man, go for it.
Tell us who you are and
your question please.
- [Aman] My name's Aman
and I'm from Burminham.
I'm from Premier Estates Wines.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Aman] I'm doing good, thanks.
The question is, we want to know,
we've taken on board a few ideas
and they're working really well.
I want to know-
- [Gary] Wait, say that one more time.
- We've taken-
I talk really fast, sorry.
We're taking on new ideas,
the DarkPost, et cetera
and it's working really well-
- [Gary] One more time.
(audience laughs)
I didn't hear it, I didn't hear it.
- We're taking on new ideas
and they're working really well,
DarkPost, et cetera.
- [Gary] Good.
- The next question is,
how can we convert Snapchat
and Pinterest into sales?
- So Snapchat, especially right now,
is much more like television
and outdoor media.
It's not DR, it's not
last touch attribution,
you're not gonna see the sale.
Though, ironically, because I'm very close
to the Snapchat infrastructure,
I'm an investor,
we're an API partner,
there's a lot of DR coming.
We ran a campaign recently for AT&T
where you swipe up from the creative
and convert the form inside.
I think Snapchat two,
three, four years from now
will be a real DR play,
a conversion sales play.
But you have to understand,
and this is actually-
Thank you so much for this question,
I'm glad I got to say this
because I've been wanting
to talk about it more.
My friends, there's a very big difference
between sales and marketing.
And we're blending them too much.
Right now, what I'm doing,
I'm doing marketing.
I'm creating awareness.
I'm giving you my ideas.
You may go down the rabbit
hole, may follow me,
you're getting into my funnel,
you've become aware of who I am.
That's marketing.
It's not-
I'm not gonna end this talk with like,
and now go to my website and buy my book.
That's not what you do.
So I think when you think about Snapchat,
think about it as marketing, right.
Listen, you know my speil.
I'm not looking for your money,
I haven't asked you for any money.
I'm building brand.
All my content is free.
You're not going down a funnel
that then charges you $100 a month.
So you need to do some of that.
Facebook is incredible for
marketing and sales, right.
Twitter's remarkable for that.
Pinterest is very easy for sales.
All those images link out.
Pinterest ads work quite well.
The problem for Pinterest,
and I'm an investor in that
company and I'm disappointed,
they have not moved to mobile
as well as they could have.
They won on desktop but they've
struggled with the mobile transition.
And I see the head nods so..
I think one thing you need,
and you're a young dude.
One thing that you need
to really understand is,
there's platforms that
are great for sales,
there's platforms that's
great for marketing
but to be really big, you have to do both.
And some platforms, Facebook,
are incredible at both
which is why they're special.
- [Aman] Okay thanks a lot.
- [Gary] You got it brother.
- [Man] I identified this question
because you said so much
about your hard work,
your discipline and what it takes
to really achieve what you've achieved.
Has a lot to do with
your regimen and with-
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean, I didn't cover it-
real quick, I didn't cover it
and so many of you raised
your hand, you know,
you didn't know who I was
and I should have probably
drank more of that in the beginning.
You know, one thing I would say,
and this is an American
thing, I do believe that
but I just believe in hard work.
You know, no matter how talented you are.
I love when people say,
Gary, you always talk about a lot of work
but I work smart.
I go, Rich, I work smart and hard,
now what asshole?
(laughter)
So, you're right.
I'm a very big believer that
if you're sitting in this room
and you're trying to achieve great things,
it's very hard to do that
in a five, seven, eight hour work day.
It just is.
Somebody's gonna work nine, 10 and 11
and that's very competitive.
But family, interests,
everybody should live their
lives they way they want to
but if you want to build something big,
if you want to create a big business,
hard work is the first second
and third part of the formula.
- [Man] Thank you so much for that.
You can't emphasize that enough.
(audience applause)
How about up there?
We've had a lot of questions
from the front rows.
How about back there in section one,
anybody with an insightful
question for Gary
before he leaves us?
He has exactly four
minutes, 33 seconds left.
- [Gary] While I've got the time
while somebody's deciding-
raise your hand if you want to do this,
but I'll say something to just bring value
during the down time.
Another thing that I want to make sure,
and there's a lot of
executives in this room,
everything you've just heard,
please make sure that you don't do-
you got a question?
Yeah, come up.
Make sure that you don't
do what everybody does
which is, if you're a senior executive
or if you own your own business,
and you heard this talk and you say,
oh wait, I think he's right,
don't go and just hire a 23 year old
and assume that they understand this.
That 23 year old was
using their mobile device
and social media to hook up with people.
No necessarily to sell stuff.
And more importantly-
and by the way, there
are some 23 year olds
that know how to sell stuff
but let's not do the cliche thing
and say, oh yes, my niece,
she's on Instagram, she's
gonna help my business.
That's not smart.
Everybody does that.
Please don't do that.
And number two, how many
people here own their business?
Raise your hand.
A lot.
So listen-
- [Man] A lot of ownership.
- [Gary] One more time,
high, I just wanna-
Okay, here's the most important part,
I'm really glad I got to say this,
everything I just talked about
so many of you are going to say,
I don't understand this, I
didn't grow up with this,
I don't know this.
If you own your own business,
don't you think it makes sense
for you to take 20 hours to either read
or watch videos on how
to place Facebook ads,
how to place Instagram ads,
how does LinkedIn work,
what is Medium.com.
When you have the audacity
to be an entrepreneur
and own your own business
and want all the riches and
great things that come with it,
you need to put in the work.
I promise you, if you look
at your eight hours everyday,
two to three of them, you're
spending on dumb shit.
(audience laughs)
you're spending it like it's 1994.
Take that back, go to YouTube and Google,
search how to place Facebook ads,
how does Snapchat work,
does Instagram work for B2B SasS,
whatever it may be,
spend 40, 50, 60 hours, do.
Because the biggest thing
I'm concerned about-
One more time, show of
hands, business owners.
The biggest concern I have
is that you're gonna hire somebody
and you have no idea what they're doing.
How are you going to judge if
that person's doing something-
by the way, if you don't understand this,
you're gonna lose either way.
Either you're gonna hire somebody
who's not gonna do shit for you
but knows how to trick you
into thinking that they are
or they're gonna do well, it's
gonna matter to your business
and then she or he will have the leverage
and either leave and do their own thing
or it will require a
lot more money from you.
You have to be the best
person in your organization-
- [Man] And do the work.
- [Gary] When I stand in
front of Vayner Media,
it's 800 people, very
young, sharp, best in class,
and when I stand in front of them and say,
I'm the best in social
media, me, the old guy,
the fucking uncle, right?
(laughter)
I'm the best-
- [Man] And the eight guys
who were finished here
that you identified.
- [Gary] That's right.
And so, to me you have
to be the best executor
in your organization.
This is communication and
communication drives everything.
- [Man] We're gonna take
that one last question
from you please, thank you.
- [Sean] Hi Gary, I'm Sean Russa.
Well, you answered my question already.
- [Gary] Well it was great to see you.
Have a good day.
- [Man] So one last question for you Gary.
- [Gary] Is that really it?
You can throw it back to him.
- [Man] We only have a minute
before our next speaker.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- [Sean] So, well I was a
bit confused with Snapchat.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I though myself I got old.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I also confirmed with my friends
who graduated with me.
- [Gary] Yes.
- They all got old.
- [Gary] Yeah, you're old.
- Yeah, so..
(laughter)
but, you know, I'm still trying.
- [Gary] You should
- I'm still trying to
understand what Snapchat,
and how can it bring the value-
- [Gary] Because, you have to understand,
and this is perfect, I've got 38 seconds,
nine years ago, Facebook was for college,
now it is not.
How does it bring value?
If Snapchat holds on,
which I think it will,
in five years my friend, you
won't be as old as you think.
You're gonna want to do business
and Snapchat is gonna
have 30 to 50 year old
Finn consumers in it's platform.
You need to figure out how
to make content in there
that makes them want to
do business with you.
- Well, trust me, I'm
spending half an hour
everyday from the last two months.
- [Gary] I love it man.
Good hustle.
- [Man] For doing the
work, thank you so much.
- Helsinki, thank you.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
- [Man] Amazing.
Gary Vaynercha. Amazing guy.
What energy.
Look at this guy, yes Helsinki.
- I love you. Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you Gary.
What energy. Thank you.
- Cool. Now comment section,
give me your favorite
thing that's happened
so far on this Thanksgiving
weekend in the US
and everybody outside the US,
what is your plans for the weekend?